let's say you've got a 747 a perfectly
good if slightly aging wide-body jet
this 747 is 40 years old NASA has owned
it for 20 of those years and if you can
make out on the back there behind the
wing sometime in that period they
decided it would be a really good idea
to cut a 16 by 20 3-foot hole into the
plane it's not just any old hole in the
fuselage it's for this this is Sofia
which stands for stratospheric
Observatory for infrared astronomy
it's a massive flying telescope operated
by NASA and the German Space Agency DLR
you might think that this is insanity or
crazy idea and there was a time
especially as we were developing it
because we ran into so many problems the
door had to work just right and it took
years to get that door to be right but
once we got it working we were getting
results that can't be done any other way
at this point Sofia has a lot in common
with the Hubble Space Telescope they're
similar sizes but where Hubble
concentrates on visible and ultraviolet
light which scientists use to make
incredible full-color images Sofia
looks primarily at infrared light which
means it can be used to study things
like the clouds of gas that will give
birth to new stars to get the best
observations the plane flies into the
stratosphere
and then opens its massive door so that
the telescope can peer into space we
climbed on board to have a look around
with Erik beckylyn Sofia's chief
scientist so we're inside a 747 you
don't really when you get on as a
passenger you don't appreciate the full
height of the plane and you're making
full use
but the full cylinder yeah no it is it
is huge there are only 30 telescopes
that are larger than Sophia but we're
flying in an aircraft it's versatile to
new equipment can be fitted to make
different kinds of observations because
it's a flying telescope it can be
positioned nearly anywhere around the
globe
it's been used to study the atmospheres
of Pluto and Mars and to look into a
black hole at the center of the galaxy
there are also stars it must be forming
there we don't know how but we have the
best picture because of this Observatory
of how that is happening the telescope
is a marvel of engineering with
gyroscopes and precision bearings
keeping it locked on its target even
through turbulence the thing I like
about Sofia
is that it brings together astronomy
which I love and I do and it brings
together airplanes everybody is excited
about airplanes but doing them together
is really very special
[Music]
you